In a stunning new poll, Republican Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell is losing
to challenger Amy McGrath in his Kentucky
Senate reelection race.
Now, I'll give you the caveats in a moment.
But the fact that this is even close is already
a really big deal.
It's typically not close at all.
In Kentucky, for Mitch McConnell in his reelections,
there's a new poll from our M.G. group and
it has Amy.
Magrath up 41 to 40.
Amy McGrath, as you may know, is an Air Force
veteran and challenging one of the one of
the longest sitting senators and the longest
ever tenured senator out of Kentucky.
Now, what's very, very interesting is that
the poll is 41 40 in favor of Amy McGrath.
It's within the margin of error, a statistical
tie.
Certainly when people participating in the
poll are told Amy McGrath favors congressional
term limits and Mitch McConnell opposes them,
which is true, her support actually increases
pretty dramatically.
But there are a lot of undecideds still in
this poll, and there are certainly a fair
number of people supporting someone other
than Mitch McConnell or Amy McGrath.
So when we typically talk about the Senate
in 2020 and we think about what's the most
likely path that Democrats could have taken
control of the Senate in 2020, we often go
to Arizona, where Mark Kelly is very much
ahead of Martha McSally, the incumbent Republican.
We'll look at Cory Gardner, Republican incumbent
in Colorado, who is well behind and may lose.
We think about Susan Collins in Maine, Thom
Tillis in North Carolina, maybe Steve Bullock
in Montana.
There's a few others.
I'm not talking about all of them, but we
don't usually talk about Mitch McConnell.
Mitch McConnell has been one of the most effective
Republican legislators in years.
He's gotten a ton of right wing judges confirmed
he successfully blocked Barack Obama's Supreme
Court pick, Merrick Garland, holding that
seat open for a year until Donald Trump was
inaugurated and ultimately selected.
Neil Gorsuch.
That is horrifying.
Horrifying.
But if you are a Republican, that's a major
accomplishment.
I mean, that should have been Barack Obama's
selection and Mitch McConnell was able to
hold it for Donald Trump.
Disgusting.
But if you're on their side, you love it.
Would be incredible to remove Mitch McConnell,
and he's currently down one.
Now, let me give you the caveat.
Mitch McConnell is down one, but it's 41 to
40.
So statistically, it's a tie.
And the challenger at some point is going
to need to get to 50 percent or close to it.
Amy McGrath is at 41.
If she can't start getting to 45, 48, closer
to 50.
Typically in these elections, the undecideds
and the third party holdouts, as we get closer
to Election Day, are going to break for the
incumbent.
In this case, it's Mitch McConnell.
So Amy McGraths ceiling could be the 41 that
she has right now, which is not going to be
enough to win it.
But it's a fight.
It's a fight and tie.
McConnell, Kentuckians should get involved
in this race.
It would be a race if you're in a state that
doesn't have a hotly contested Senate seat.
You could get involved in phone banking and
fundraising for Amy McGrath.
McConnell has been in the U.S. Senate longer
than any other senator from Kentucky has ever
been.
Mitch McConnell went to the Senate in 1985,
the year after I was born.
Mitch McConnell went to the Senate and Mitch
McConnell is still in the Senate.
It's too much.
He's got to go.
He's been a Senate majority leader for five
years since 2015, and he has left a massive
destruction in his wake.
And if indeed Mitch McConnell loses, it would
be a huge bellwether for how the entire Senate
is going.
You know, we usually when we do analysis,
we say here's how this one race is going.
Here's how this other race is going.
The reality is that these things come in waves.
If the incumbent from 1985, Republican majority
leader is knocked out in Kentucky, a lot of
these other races are likely to go in the
direction of Democrats.
And we will probably, if that happens, have
Donald Trump to think seats and states that
are rarely, if ever, in play for Democrats
are now a fight.
Even forcing Republicans to have to spend
money to defend them is a victory because
these are often very easy to win states and
races for Republicans.
So pick a race if it's in your state.
Great.
If you're in a state without a close election,
find something nearby or something you're
interested in.
There is plenty to be done.
And this being Kentucky, I'm thinking about
getting a nice bottle of Kentucky bourbon
to have for election night coverage.
And if Mitch McConnell loses on November 3rd,
maybe we'll open that up, even though it will
be a very big uphill battle.
But by the way, the warning is because this
polling is close, this piggybacks on the earlier
story about the suppression we saw yesterday
in Georgia because this election is close.
We should expect that Kentucky Republicans
are going to go extra hard on the voter suppression
and the other types of election fraud tactics.
So we will likely need extra margin if Amy
Magrath is to defeat Mitch McConnell.
It's been happening this week in Georgia and
elsewhere.
Massive poll closures creating very large
waits in disproportionately democratic areas.
We know the tactics, but we've got to fight
them.
OK, next week.
Tuesday night, 8:00 p.m. Eastern, we will
be having the second David Pakman show chess
tournament.
This is free to all.
This is not members only.
There's no fee.
This is just free.
It's just building sportsmanship and camaraderie
in a difficult time.
So that'll be Tuesday, June 16th, at 8:00
p.m. Eastern.
The tournament will be on Lee Chess dot org.
I'll have more info about that.
But put it in your calendar.
I hope you'll play.
We had 500 players last time and I hope we
do better than that.
In the meantime, make sure to let me know
what you think about this MacConnell race
on Twitter.